reminding yourself every day of how
amazing you are i think is one of the
greatest gifts you can give yourself
and it's not about ego it's about
confidence
confidence comes from a place of
strength ego
comes from a place of weakness and
insecurity so it's time
to step into your confidence and remind
yourself
of how amazing you really are so i used
to have a lot of problems
with with ego versus confidence i used
to feel like
who am i why do people need to hear my
story
uh i was profoundly all these different
successful entrepreneurs and people kept
asking where are you
how come we can't see what you're about
where did you come from and i always
felt like
my story doesn't matter i'm profiling
david goggins and steve jobs and
and all these people why do you care
about i mean sure i sold my first
business how to had an exit but it's
nothing compared to what all these other
people have done and i always
shrouded it covered it under ego like
well that's such an egotistical thing to
do
but really i was just playing small i
was cheating people the opportunity to
learn to get better to grow
from my story my story has value it's
the belief
that my story had value that took some
time to really work up
even making videos on my channel the
number one most requested person for top
10 was me
and i resisted for maybe two years of
even making
an evan carmichael top ten because i
just felt not good enough i felt like
that's such an ego play and not coming
from a place of confidence
and yes my message has impact has
meaning can
help the world and the first evan
carmichael top 10 came out from my team
so my birthday
birthday i think it was my birthday
birthday or christmas my team put
together
with the with the support of my hardcore
fans my first
top ten and that's the one that that
went live on a channel and ever since
then we've done
a regular series of me being on the
channel but it's been a real
progress for me it's been a real
evolution it's taken me a long time and
hopefully you can get there faster it's
been
almost 20 years of me sharing ideas and
content
and and slowly stepping into the light
and slowly building more confidence more
belief
and i hope that with the content i'm
making and the experiences i'm sharing
you can get there a lot faster